after all the hype and build up and in
spite of the many obstacles putting our
way our event at slu happened last night
or slew which is apparently what the
students call it and they didn't tell me
that until the q a and i was calling it
slu the entire time
um but i'm just going to stick with slu
anyway
enormous crowds we had a room with a
capacity of 200 people i think we fit
450 people into it
plus a plus plus an overflow room so it
was great and then of course there was
the mob of protesters outside blocking
traffic
i did decide to go outside and confront
the protesters personally
not confront i wanted to go i wanted to
talk to them have a conversation
and also give them a chance to answer
the what is a woman question because
that was my challenge
i did say that before i came on campus i
said if anyone can come
to my talk and and define if any
leftists can come and define the word
woman and do it successfully i will
admit defeat and i will never speak on
another college campus ever again
and um none of them actually showed up
to the talk to me my my challenge so i
went out to them and um
uh not you know is it necessarily a
smart or safe thing to go out to go walk
out into the middle of the street and
talk to the angry mob of insane people
who've come to protest you
probably not
but i don't often choose the uh the
smart path so no reason to start now i
figure but rather than me recapping it
i'll play this report from cbs which
which is actually surprisingly fair they
were there and they captured some of
this including
me and my my i suppose conversation with
protesters let's watch that
a conservative speaker's views sparking
protests tonight st louis university
students invited matt walsh to speak
he's a commentator for the conservative
media outlet the daily wire news 4's
caroline hecker was there as the clash
of opinions hit the streets of midtown
a clash of views
outside the coronado near slough's
campus wednesday night ahead of the
arrival of conservative speaker matt
walsh
but the controversy began weeks ago
walsh was originally scheduled to speak
at a building on campus but says the
university's coveted measures were too
strict saint francis xavier church also
on campus then volunteered
to play host but the president of slu's
college republicans says at the last
minute the priest changed his mind we're
very disappointed to see that the church
would rescind the invitation especially
on such short notice father dan white
released this statement claiming
comments made by walsh quote run
contrary to the values of catholic faith
resulting in the event being canceled
but that's just not true matt is a
devout catholic
his views
are in like
very good alignment with the church
students then secured an off-campus
location drawing long lines wednesday
night
before the speech walsh came outside to
speak with the protesters who accuse him
of being racist and transphobic those
inside say while they don't expect
everyone to agree civil discourse is
important i don't think matt walsh is
some kind of extremist or anything like
that i think he's pretty normal and
mainstream in the conservative media so
i think it's very very important for you
know colleges to accept that
even they may not agree i still think
that the first amendment's pretty
important and it's very important for
students to be able to you know hear
from a different perspective we spoke
with dozens of slu students before the
event started who were waiting in line
none of them wanted to talk to us on
camera telling me they were fearful that
giving their opinions could make them a
target on campus
well what does that tell you probably
the most revealing thing in the whole
thing they were there they don't want to
be on camera talking about it because
and can you blame them given given where
they're going to school
the kind of treatment i got and the
great thing for me is that i can show up
and cause a lot of trouble and then
leave
but they have to stay there on campus
so i give a lot of credit to students
who uh made this
just no matter what they they were gonna
make this event happen and uh so a lot
of credit to them for doing that well
unfortunately i don't have the knives
with me the kamikoto knives normally
when we do this ad i like to i like to
flail the knives around and show them
off but i can't i couldn't get them
through airport security we're in a
hotel right now but kamikoto knives
kamikoto uh taps into more than 800
years of traditional techniques from
honshu japan each kamikota knife goes
through a rigorous 19-step process that
takes several years from start to finish
to complete because of their single
bevel edge kamikoto knives can achieve
an unbelievably sharp edge that you just
can't get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter these
are beautiful knives they're very sharp
they're very uh they are very effective
and they're in there like as i said
they're beautiful looking as well cami
coated knives are used by several chefs
working at michelin star restaurants and
once you buy these things for yourself
you can tell why uh the the the best
chefs in the world like to use them so
click the link below or go to
kamikoto.com matt walsh news promo code
matt walsh to save an extra 50 today
why did i go out there to talk to them
well for one thing it's only polite to
go and say hi to people that have come
out
you know because of you
and for another these people are cowards
um
and we we are far too often intimidated
by
cowards
when because they're in large groups
you know individually they're they're
they won't even show up
none of those people not not one single
person from that crowd went inside
certainly to hear the talk or or to they
they had a chance in the q a you can
take the microphone
and if you think that you can embarrass
me
by exposing my ideas as being bigoted
and all that kind of stuff
why not take that why not take that
opportunity if i'm really if i'm really
just a raging bigot a stupid raging
bigot well and that should be very easy
to
uncover in a conversation where you have
a microphone
but they're not going to do that because
then it's one-on-one
and they don't want to be in that kind
of position um they always want to they
always want to operate in groups
and when they all come together we put
put a bunch of cows together
together in a group people become
intimidated
and we cannot be intimidated
so yeah i'll just go go right out there
and talk to them what are they going to
do
i was walking up i don't know if it was
caught we actually we have footage
ourselves that we um that we took and i
put it up some of them up on twitter
i'll put it up on instagram also and i
think you it captures this moment where
i'm walking up to the crowd
and uh one of the guys comes comes
forward and says screams do not come
over here and then so i came over there
and he just backed away
so pretty pretty great and as i was
standing there also it was fun to watch
because the crowd was originally in the
street blocking traffic but as i was
standing there they all started backing
away and then very very soon were off of
the street
so it's just me and like
200 people
and they're afraid is that because i'm
i'm a big bad wolf i'm big and scary no
it's just because they're absolute
cowards
and they're and they're not ready to be
challenged and not expecting it
and don't know what to do when they
are um and they have a fragile this this
world view that they've constructed
and that they have uh
subscribed to is very very fragile
and it cannot withstand
any inspection any cross-examination
so that was good
although i will say one other one other
note about this is that um
the talk almost
didn't happen at all not for the reasons
that you've heard about but um
i will admit that uh we were we were
flying out of dc to go to st louis
and somehow we ended up going to the
wrong airport
um and so i own i we we almost missed
the flight i was at the wrong airport we
went to dulles we're supposed to be at
reagan
and uh we had like 45 minutes to get
over the airport get through security
and i almost missed the flight i'm just
thinking
my god after all of this if the talk is
shut down because i had to cancel it
because i went to the wrong airport and
missed my flight
that
that that would be
that would be the one way to for me to
pull an hell out of this whole situation
but thankfully that didn't happen if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and share it with all your
friends